[Music]
one day 15 years ago everything changed
it was covered in this wounds someone
dumb in the source whatever this rules
was it transformed us it was weird but
we became a family
[Music]
boys Where Have You Been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Spooner some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it you ratted
us out hey don't use that word that way
I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
a lot of your teeth I want to know
everything about you our dad is
definitely not a giant rat that makes me
feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
I can't believe there are other mutants
you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have a wisdom Raphael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage problem right
it's not a problem
[Music]